oh my god where are we going
[Music]
oh my gosh you guys we have the cokes
bacon burrito and I'm not to show you
that ski look at that
[Music]
everywhere
I went to the vegetarian I love that
Dean and wanting to give it a try but
tiny cheese veggie
and this has scrambled egg let me show
you
so October
look at Archie
and I love that the egg and scram will
be about nine
they're doing amazing things in there
come to the jokes it's great see you the
next stop
[Music]
we just got three burritos you're not
so this is a veggie it has potato tomato
cheese a lot of cheese I really like
background music
[Music]
do you
so Nick wants me to try the hot links
apparently is
ever
[Music]
that case oh it was so good
take my mom my dad my brother my sister
auntie
no one said Oaks gourmet really made me
feel good all the ingredients were very
like healthy I felt Koufax my personal
favorite there's a hot link burrito and
it's incredibly hot late for that one
I'm gonna have to say the bacon looks
best for oats the veggie and that's it
for this time
[Music]